hey I'm Marcus eighties film buff  idealist hacker in this this is my home  all I ever wanted was right here from  the city to Oakland were in the Silicon  Valley the entire Bay Area is a playpen  for counterculture free spirits set in  the new norm decades ahead of time just  take your curiosity for a walk or ride  any bride  there's always something going on  no matter where you end up it'll leave  its mark on and yours on it only one  rule around here tech rules everything  tech is power and with power comes  corruption corporations manipulating  data and citizens on a massive scale  making their world better and ours worse  it's time we take back control I got  this I can hack anyone I can hack it  this place  it's a playground for a guy like me  welcome to san francisco watch youtubers  play watchdogs to  you